I'm Eddie Brock I'm the reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
looking at I found something actually
start to hear from the fans they're
gonna start seeing this movie in a
couple of days that's really important
and like the good thing is there's an EP
I actually want them this is an
introduction piece to venom it's
obviously a standalone movie and I'm I'm
very happy with that and that's what I
get involved with in the first place so
we've got plenty of characters in the
universe to play with but what's good
about the corner response and I know
that comic fans are not you know shy and
coming forward and I'm more than happy
to hear that I mean I question whether
or not they're happy with like what
we've done to bring Eddie Brock and
venom to the forefront what we could do
better and how they'd like us to to work
with it really ultimately so I know we
will be judged and I know that you know
there's diehard fans and that's cool but
at the end of the day I think we
presently play and come with something
so a really cool movie I like to believe
they're gonna say you did a fantastic
job I wanna be thank you now I
understand also yeah yeah it's a cool
free yeah he has seen it he was pretty
much in the driving seat for a lot of it
and and I did use him as my life my
anthology and like mythology what wizard
he told me what I was doing wrong and
and I was doing more things wrong than I
was doing right because children are
deeply honest and so he was mine it was
spirit guide in aspects so as far as I'm
concerned like I passed his yeah and
that's that's the best I can do but I
wouldn't want a singing and dancing
number in there somewhere possibly in a
sequel because other we should push push
their boundaries maybe a bit of figure
skating I love that yeah that's gonna
which super villain or antihero you want
to play next but we do so hop
for another film I mean actually that's
the idea we went into this hoping to
build it they know and I went in to be
open to do something for the next
several years that I can invest myself
in but first we have to launch it and
see well how do people feel about it and
if they don't like it we'll see but I
don't I don't feel they will I've got a
really good feeling about it I know that
the whole team called a lot of love into
it and I really really enjoy it
I've list you know I've lifted a lot of
stuff out there today that I did I did a
lot of improvisation on it and including
some singing and dancing and it will
never make it's the movie but you know
as an exec do so we have to say no we
have to stick to the story Tom but I
want to get back out there on a sequin
and play with it and see how far we can
people play with the double axe and
stuff so and whatever the fans want last
thing your director told me to ask you
you actually were able to do the venom
voice on set as well if you were
improving tonight what would what we've
done and have to say about this you
Devine someone already we wouldn't be
here right now
it would have all gone a bit Pete Tong
and there'd be a villain somewhere in
there so this would just be the facade
of some
[Music]
[Applause]